je voudrais 6 partager avec vous ce soir
une expérience fabuleuse et ça s'est
passé en octobre 1996 elle ça dure
encore aujourd'hui
à l'époque j'étais président d'une
société spécialisée dans l'étude la
conception et la réalisation de systèmes
de sécurité et je venais de réaliser une
corbeille ou une poubelle
résistant aux explosions est on en avait
équipé la ville de paris le louvre la
pyramide inversée le trocadéro excédent
c'est alors que je fus convoqué par le
ministère de la culture et la
communication pour me communiquer que le
18 décembre 1994 une grotte venait
d'être découvert que celle ci possédait
des peintures rupestres des gravures et
des ossements unique au monde et qui
datait environ - trente-six mille ans
pour éviter tout risque il me demandait
de réaliser une protection de cet
ensemble de ce joyau course a bien
évidemment je me suis rendu sur 6 sur
place et en arrivant j'ai rencontré les
inventeurs qui était eliette brunel jean
marie chauvet
et christian hillaire la grotte allait
prendre le nom de chauvel et c'est alors
que oui je lis pas je vais aller visiter
alors en arrivant sur place au mas
alliés j'ai mis une combinaison un
casque avec une lumière frontale est une
torsion l'entrée était relativement et
droites suivies d'un boyau d'environ 10
mètres de long et qui arrivaient au
dessus de la grotte après être descendu
sur le sol où tout était qualifié je me
meurs tel à ce genre de choses je ne
connaissais rien à l'art rupestre
né à l'aspect jeu fut choqué par
l'immensité la grandeur que l'on
rencontrait pour tous ceux qui
apparaissaient les peintures rupestres
les gran au sol et des bouquetins et
source et rennes quelque chose se
mélangeaient c'était impressionnant
je me disais mais où est ce que je suis
eh bien je venais d'entrer dans le plus
grand joie you de l'art pariétal au
monde sur la droite
j'aime
je vis ce hibou se dévouent qui a été
entièrement dessiné il y a trente six
mille ans sur de la terre avec des mains
et puis sur le mur des dessins de rennes
les dessins de chevaux nous avons des
lionnes
il faut savoir qu'à l'époque il avait
utilisé les fissurations de la roche
pour donner les effets de relief la
grandeur de ses représentations me
faisait contrer dans un autre monde dans
quelque chose que je ne connaissais
absolument pas tu t'es un peu perdue je
lave ou et lorsque je me suis retourné
je me suis retrouvé nez à nez avec
quelques centimètres à cheval et ce
cheval il me regarde l intention
lorsque je passais les yeux au sol
il y avait encore du charbon de bois
je me suis rendu compte que je venais de
pénétrer dans un lieu inviolée depuis
des milliers d'années et je me trouvais
à l'emplacement même où un être avait
dessiné ce cheval et j'étais incapable
moi de faire je me disais mais c'est pas
possible
où est ce que je suis et puis en me
retournant
une paire bestiaire ce vestiaire quand
il est animé par les torches qui avait à
l'époque les aurignacien puisque ce à
l'époque des humiliations
il avait des tensions parce que nous
avons retrouvé des mouflage sur les murs
et l'oscillation du feu faisait avancer
les animaux me disaient ils ont
découvert le dessin animé ils ont
découvert le début du cinéma
et puis là une panthère sur la gauche
une lionne d'un centre l'oeil était
dessiné en utilisant aussi les
fissurations s était sur un rocher qui
était absent au milieu donc il fallait
le contourner et en le contournant je
regardais cette lionne s continuer à me
suivre
elle continue à me regarder j'étais pas
très bien j'avais des frissons
j'avais l'impression que quelque chose
observé que quelque chose il n'était pas
logique pour moi je me suis vite
peut-être que cette drogue thème corps
habité
alors je poursuis tranquillement et là
en levant la tête
le ciel est noir vous avez l'impression
d'être en orbite
puisque on sait bien que en dehors d'un
sommet en orbite autour de la terre
neuve
et puis cette immensité tout autour
alors ce frisson cette façon d'être et
un crâne un cran de poser sur un rocher
ce crâne entièrement calcifié 36 milan
et à sang l'endroit où ils se
réunissaient où ils vivent est un seul
endroit où l'hadopi questions questions
questions je n'ai pas arrêté de me poser
des questions je n'ai jamais eu de
réponse et je relis toujours pas
aujourd'hui que faisait-il à l'époque
étaient ils voulaient team nous
représenter leur vie de tous les jours
ou alors nous passer un message un
message pour l'humanité je continue à
travailler sur cette sécurité la
sécurité de l'ensemble de la côte chaude
et pour continuer à pratiquer airs
conserver ce joyau de l'art rupestre se
trouve à vallon-pont-d'arc pour éviter
ceci ne vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]